don't let negativity get you down a
little while ago I wrote a newsletter
for my list
I bought a time when I was really
panicking I remember when I got my first
place you know I moved out of my
apartment and I bought my first place
and I got so excited I was so happy to
have my own place you know finally I
felt like I was growing up and and I I
was a success even though it wasn't a
huge place this is town house but it's
my own you know I'm I did that and after
I signed the agreement I realized that
what if I couldn't make all the payments
on this mortgage edit just took on and I
started to panic I started to freak out
like my heart was beating I was sweating
and just a paralyzing fear that this
isn't gonna work out what's gonna happen
I don't want to be losing all my savings
and end up on the street and just the
embarrassment of all that and I used the
panic to fuel me I used the panic to
make me work harder I used the panic to
you know when was midnight I was getting
tired I was so scared of losing my house
that I work until 3:00 in the morning I
worked harder I put more into it I gave
everything I had into it I stop playing
games and stop wasting my time and
getting distracted I focused
I used that negativity to make me
stronger and move me closer to achieving
my goal as people and as entrepreneurs
you have a choice there's gonna be a lot
of negative emotions that will surround
your they'll surround you either ones
that you give yourself like panic or
ones that other people put on you like
doubt and fear and worry and anger and
it's how you react to them that makes
all the difference in the world because
you have a choice to either let those
negative thoughts and experiences bring
you down or let them act as fuel to make
you stronger you
look at kids for example and I've looked
at a few studies of kids who grew up in
battered homes and they were they were
abused by their parents spanked or worse
or you know cigarette butts on them and
just terrible stuff and you can look at
two siblings who come from the same
household and one of them goes on to the
exact same thing to their kids they beat
them they punish them they're abusive
and and they say one like that because
look at the look at the environment I
came from look what my parents did and
they let that negativity creep into
their lives and you can have their
brother or sister grew up in the same
family suffered the same thing and they
go on to be great parents and they never
hit their child and they're they're
loving and respectful and when you ask
them why is that they give the same
answer is they're simple and they say
well look at what I grew up in I never
want to be like that they use that
negativity as an example of what not to
do and to fuel them to be better you
have a choice this is a conscious
decision that you can make when somebody
tells you that it's not going to work
out when somebody's hating on your idea
when you're worried something is not
going to work out when you're angry at
something when you're frustrated by
something you can either use that to
bring you down to hide to shrink down to
live a mediocre life to be unhappy or
you use that as fuel to make you
stronger to be better to say this is not
acceptable and I'm going to find a
solution for it this comes as a result
of a question from one of my newsletter
readers Roisin who wouldn't say can I
assume that Panik always brings out good
outcomes or sometimes it can cause
errors it's really how you react to it
the point here is it's a conscious
choice at some time in your life you're
gonna feel panic we all do you're gonna
feel lots of pain you're gonna feel
pressure you're gonna feel stress you're
going to feel anger
you're gonna feel hatred it's all in how
you react to those things you have the
choice you make a decision to either let
those things bring you down and you
become angry and hateful and hopeless
and and bring that to other people you
know people are angry and hate it hate
towards you you could bring that to
other people your friends you start
getting angry on them you start hating
on them or you can use that to make you
stronger to show us an example of what
you don't want to be what you don't want
to embody and use it as fuel to make
your business a reality believe thanks
for the question feely for you guys
watching liked the video please give it
a thumbs up I loved seeing us come in
let me know what you think do you let
negativity bring you down how do you
overcome it leave it in the comments
below you have a question I want to hear
from you I'll make a video response
leave it below I read all the comments
that come in I eat my breakfast every
morning my lentils and I read your
questions and that's what gets me going
every day so please leave something
below if you've never left the comment
now's your chance thank you guys so much
and I'll see you soon
you